20 90s almost here and from a wide
selection of anime we've gathered a few
that we think show a lot of promise in
the coming year here's our list of the
most anticipated anime of 2019 to start
off at number 10 we have boogie pop
doesn't laugh there's an urban legend
that children tell one another about a
Shinigami that can release people from
the pain they may be suffering the name
of this Angel of Death is boogie pop
when a rash of disappearances involving
female students breaks out as shaneoh
academy the police and faculty assume
they just have a bunch of runaways on
their hands but Nagi Karima knows better
something mysterious and foul is afoot
the boogie pop is a psychological
mystery and horror series by madhouse
studios and is set to air on January the
4th
[Music]
one two one two three four at number
nine is the second season of mob psycho
100 from the writer of one punch man the
first season of this action comedy
supernatural series was such a huge hit
but now it's back for a second season
the series depicts Shiggy Oh an average
schoolboy who's also called mob we
discover he actually has powerful
abilities and is overpowered by them
thus becoming quite dangerous this is a
story of finding the balance between
being a normal boy and having powers
beyond your control and mob seems to be
losing on his psychic powers the first
episode of season 2 will be released on
January the 7th at number 8 we have the
rising of the shield hero the
announcement of the release date of
tatty no yuusha was received positively
as the manga series has been quite
successful the series will seek to
breathe life into the characters on
screen as we join it with tiny now a for
me who's summoned into a parallel world
along with three other people to become
the world's heroes along with these
gifts they're tasked with saving the
world from its prophesized destruction
as the legendary shield bearer melih for
me is considered the weakest in the
group and doesn't receive esteem from
his peers
soon after being betrayed and losing
everything but his shield
now if Umi must rise to become the
legendary shield hero and save the world
the anime series is scheduled to
premiere on January the 9th but does
shimmer or deny Dada
at number 7 it's the promised Neverland
this story follows a group of children's
escape from an orphanage
the grace-filled house is a small
orphanage that housed Emma one of our
lead characters and have 37 siblings
everything is Mary as the orphans are
basically allowed to do as they please
except to venture out of the compounds
of the house one fateful night two of
the orphans sneak out and see the farm
for what it really is
it promises mystery as well as drama as
we joined the orphans determined
attempts to escape the clutches of
Isabella and the demons the promised
Neverland was ranked at number 8 in the
top-selling manga in Japan of 2018 which
is noteworthy considering it was the
only Series in the top ten which never
had an anime the series premiere date is
January the 11th at number 6 we have
demon slayer Kim ETSU no llevar based on
the manga series by Korea Haruka taug a
commit soon oh yeah best centers around
the life of Tangier oh Kamado a
kind-hearted intelligent boy who lives
with his family and makes money by
selling charcoal Tangier owes life
changes forever when his family is
slaughtered by demons his little sister
Natsuko is the only survivor that she's
been transformed into a demon herself
the adventure begins when Tangier o and
his sister depart in search of vengeance
and a way to get in a Zuko to become
human again the series will premiere in
April and will be animated by Studio you
for table
[Music]
at number five we have my hero academia
season 4 my hero academia is a series
that is constantly hitting the top of
the charts as one of the most popular
anime with all meit's retirement what
does that mean for the safety of the
population all might been the main
deterrent of crime for the past few
years and with him out of the picture
the villains have been popping up more
often with the rise of the League of
villains midoriya feels the weight of
his success are all might now more than
ever
at number four we have one punch man
season two if you haven't seen one punch
man you've been missing out on some
comedic action-packed gold here we have
another anime that's hit the top of the
charts at one of the most sought after
shows with fans patiently waiting for
season two after his intense training
regimen Saitama the main protagonist
obtains the ability to obliterate almost
any enemy with one strike one punch man
is a quick and easy show to get into
with intense fight scenes beautiful
animation and hints of comedic relief
say Tama is essentially a hero for fun
who's always on the lookout for strong
enemies to take down will Saitama ever
find the matchup of his dreams one punch
man season two is set to air in April
cheedo yet they do monitor
[Music]
at number three it's the second core of
attack on Titan season three attack on
Titans a fast-paced anime that keeps you
on the edge of your seat humanity is
trapped within the confines of a massive
walls that protect them from human
devouring Titans easily being one of the
most highly watched anime this is a show
that everyone has their eyes on the show
is left off where Titans have taken over
the outer wall Maria and they must plug
in the hole the colossal Titan made to
take back their land to help with
overpopulation and food shortages ending
the third season with radical plot
twists what will happen next as the main
protagonist ventures off into Titan
territory in attempt to save humanity as
they know it
this season promises a lot more action
and is set for release in April
at number 2 we have fruits baskets 2019
the series follows the life of Tohru
Honda an orphan teenage girl the story
starts with her living in a tent before
encountering the Sohma family after
being taken in by them she realizes
they're cursed to transform into zodiac
animals whenever they're weak under
stress or hugged by someone of the
opposite sex sworn to secrecy she sets
out to break the curse with some
romantic moments as well as humor we're
excited for the remake of fruits baskets
and finally at number one we have
Vinland saga one of the most anticipated
shows from award-winning author Mikoto
Yukimura is set up in Dane controlled
England at the start of the 11th century
it features Vikings and the story
combines a dramatization of King Canute
the Great's rise to power
revenge is a major theme as we follow a
young fighter named tor Finn who's
trying to avenge his father's death by
the hand of a mercenary leader known as
Oscar lad
it promises intense action from the
Viking warriors the premiere date hasn't
been announced but it is set to be
released in 2019 so what do you guys
think of this list then if there are any
particular videos that you want us to
create then do comment below and let us
know and of course leave a like if
you've enjoyed this particular video do
feel free to subscribe if you haven't
and hit the notification button so that
you never ever miss out on any of our
new uploads you'll always be in the note
and find out straightaway we'll see you
next time on vinnie tube goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]